- Pour poursuivre la discussion,
merci d'être là. Tour de table.
Qu'est-ce qui est le plus
important selon vous à retenir
de son règne?
- Ce que je retiens pour la
ville de Québec, c'est la
fierté, la confiance, le plaisir
retrouvé, un sentiment
d'appartenance qui avait été un
peu émoussée, on avait pas fini
de digérer les fusions quand il
est arrivé en poste.
Évidemment, il y a eu des
périodes plus difficiles. Il y a
un certain drame. Mais je pense
que cet esprit est resté. Je
retiens qu'il a beaucoup marqué
sa ville et qu'il a contribué à
la transformer. Québec
aujourd'hui par sa rockstar,
celui qui représentait Québec
sur toutes les tribunes. Comme
journaliste, on ne sait jamais
ennuyer.
- On voit les anneaux
olympiques. C'était un de ces
projets. Sébastien, qu'est-ce
que vous retenez?
- Les fêtes du 400e
anniversaires.
Il pensait vouloir inviter un
invité de marque, il a pensé au
pape mais il était déjà pris. Il
a pensé à Paul McCartney. Faire
venir un britannique sur les
plaines d'Abraham pour fêter
l'anniversaire de la ville de
Québec. Il y a eu une petite
controverse, mais c'est passé
rapidement à côté. C'est là que
le sentiment de fierté est
revenu à Québec.
- Martine?
- C'est tout un monument de la
politique municipale qui s'en
va. Un être bourru, pas toujours
gentil avec les journalistes
notamment, et avec les gens
aussi. Mais un homme de coeur qi
a compris qu'on ne faisait pas
d'omelette sans casser des oeuf.
Et il en a cassé des oeufs. Sa
persévérance dans le dossier du
tramway est remarquable.
Avec Philippe Couillard, il a
gardé un contact, il s'apprécie
beaucoup c'est de la. Quand
Monsieur Legault est arrivé au
pouvoir, ça a été plus
difficile. Il s'entend bien avec
Monsieur Legault, mais le caucus
de Québec, c'est autre chose.
Geneviève Guilbault, il ne
s'entendait pas tellement bien.
Le tramway a failli dérailler en
bonne partie à cause du caucus
de Québec. Et c'est finalement
Monsieur Legault et François
Bonnardel qui ont récupéré le
dossier. En coulisse chez
François Bonnardel, on disait
qu'on aurait bien apprécié que
la responsable de la ville de
Québec donne un coup de talon
haut sur la table et ramène le
leadership du caucus de Québec
ensemble. Le jour où Monsieur
Labeaume est venu à l'Assemblée
nationale pour rencontrer
Monsieur Lebeau pour régler le
problème du tramway, je vous
rappellerai que Madame Geneviève
Guilbault était à la période des
questions, on avait réservé ça à
14 heures un mardi pour être sûr
qu'elle n'y assiste pas.
- Elle avait de la misère à dire
tramway. Il a réussi et il a dit
que si ça n'avait pas été mis
sur les rails, il n'aurait pas
pu partir. Ce qu'on a appelé le
vivre ensemble, parlons plus
directement de la tragédie de la
mosquée, sans la secouer comme
ça à secouer beaucoup de monde.
Je pense que son image, des gens
peut-être hors Québec, l'image
de lui à changer.
VALÉRIE PLANTE,
- Cette capitale nationale vient
de vivre un drame.
Aucun pays ne devrait vivre un
drame en conséquence de sa race
ou de son orientation sexuelle.
- L'ont découvert un nouveau
maire, un nouveau Régis
Labeaume?
- Peut-être que des gens qui ne
le connaissaient pas ont
découvert une facette qui était
moins connue. C'est un homme
assez complexe. Il a des côtés
un peu intimidants. Mais c'est
aussi un homme très sensible. Il
a étudié en théâtre et en
sociologie. Je le place plutôt
au centre gauche sur l'échiquier
politique. On n'en a beaucoup
moins parlé que de ces grands
projets, mais c'est un homme qui
a toujours montré de la
sensibilité pour les causes des
plus démunis, les oeuvres
caritatives. Il s'est beaucoup
engagé de ce côté, beaucoup plus
que les marques qui l'ont
précédé. C'est un aspect de lui
qu'on connaît moins, mais ça
fait parti de lui. Il était dans
ses oeuvres là avant d'arriver n
politique.
- Quand il parlait des deux
tragédies, on sentait que ça été
une période difficile.
- Il a dit qu'il n'avait pas
vécu de la politique mais pour
la politique. C'est un homme
très entier dans tous les
dossiers. Ça le touchait ce que
les gens vivaient à Québec. Il a
parlé des grandes réussites et
des ratés.
Quand la tuerie de la mosquée,
ça a été terrible pour lui, il a
toujours été très compatissant
par rapport à la suite de cet
événement. Et à chaque année
quand on commémore ce moment, on
le sent très affecté par cet
événement.
- Il y avait le danger avec la
tragédie de la mosquée que
Québec se divise. Il fallait
rassembler les gens de Québec
autour de ce drame. Et faire la
promotion de ce qu'on appelle le
vivre ensemble. Il y avait aussi
l'image de Québec. Il a dit que
quand deux jours de suite vous
êtes la deuxième nouvelle, il y
a un travail à faire pour
rassurer les gens sur l'image de
Québec. Il regroupait les
qualités qu'on attend chez un
politicien : passion, conviction
et authenticité. Des fois ça
sortait tout croche ou c'était
impétueux, mais il avait cette
passion qu'on attendait
politicien.
- La barre est haute pour le
prochain ou la prochaine.
- Absolument. Il occupait tous
les terrains politiques qu'on
peut imaginer, que ce soit en
environnement, le plan
économique, tous les gens un
socio. Il était de tous les
enjeux. Il y a un parti qui a
opposé au tramway, évidemment ça
risque d'être un enjeu de la
prochaine bataille électorale de
l'automne. Monsieur Labeaume est
arrivé et profiter du décès de
la mairesse Boucher à l'époque,
on se retrouve un peu dans la
même situation.
- Il nous a mit l'eau à la
bouche en nous disant : vous
verrez. J'ai l'impression qu'il
va faire campagne.
- Il s'agit de savoir si la
préparer la relève. Il avait un
bras droit qui est parti faire
d'autres choses. Est-ce qu'elle
pourrait revenir en politique?
Les spéculations vont aller bon
train, mais il ne sera jamais
loin pour appuyer quelqu'un